voici les actuels usagers des voies du
tcsp à ce jour des taxis collectifs ou
de place des piétons et des motards
aucun bus à haut niveau de service à
l'horizon
pourtant la marche à blanc a bien été
réalisée le 22 septembre dernier le
président de la ctm alfred marie-jeanne
annonçait la mise en service du tcsp
gratuitement coup de théâtre hier c'est
louis boutrin qui déclare sur une chaîne
concurrente que l'exploitation
commerciale du tcsp débuterait avant le
15 janvier une information que la cft eu
pourtant en charge de l'exploitation
commerciale découvre comme tout le monde
en regardant la télévision le 15 si nous
avons les moyens nous ferons si nous
avons tout ce qu'il faut
si nous avons toutes les autorisations
si nous avons tous les moyens techniques
si nous avons tous les moyens financiers
si nous avons tous les moyens juridiques
nous serons en capacité de faire c'est
cela dont il faut avoir la garantie lors
de ces réunions du 11 et du 12 il faut
que les éléments soient mises en place
moi je ne doute pas que l'autorité
délégante
le sache et que donc peut-être qu'il ya
union travail qui a été fait pierre
labbe le mans qui nous permettrait
d'agir et de travailler en toute
sécurité et en sérénité
on a du mal à imaginer comment le tcsp
pour être entré dans sa phase de
commercialisation le 15 janvier quand
des réunions importantes prévues les 11
et 12 janvier doit déterminer les
conditions juridiques financières et
techniques de cette fameuse exploitation
commerciale
réponse de louis boutrin premier
vice-président de martinique transports
ces questions sont déjà réglés son coup
d'éclat d'hier était calculée et vise à
mettre la pression sur la cft u qui
bloque selon lui le processus de mise en
service du tcsp pour se faire payer la
marche à blanc 1,2 million d'euros par
mois au lieu des cinq cent soixante
mille euros convenu soit le double
presque ce que nous disons aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on ne peut plus continuer chez
ceux situation au les bus à haut niveau
de service ne circule pas celui qui peut
faire circuler
c'est le délégataire et maintenant le
donneur donne ce n'est plus la cacem si
martin transports il maquille transport
dit nous allons négocier de manière à
savoir exactement quel est le coût parce
que nous n'avons toujours pas les
justificatifs de la marche à blanc à un
million deux cent mille euros
nous allons demander ces justificatifs
et faute de justificatifs nous allons
effectivement mettre la pression et nous
vous l'annonçons qu'effectivement nous
mettions une pression nous prenons nos
responsabilités pour dès que ça assez
duré il faut que ces bus circulent c'est
donc un bras de fer qui s'amorce entre
martinique transport gestionnaire du
tcsp depuis le 2 janvier
et la cft nu sur fond de bataille
politique historique entre le ppm et le
mime
quant au lancement du tcsp le 15 janvier
il reste hypothétique